so if we look at the European makes the
basic decision yeah it's not the
nationally the basic decisions are made
by the IMF unelected Commission and the
central bank in Brussels and the reason
one of the reasons why we're seeing in
Europe the spread of populism in
opposition for the establishment
established in conclusion to the
centrist under license no working
parties that have the fund money about
rage anger fear part of the reason is
that the decision-making has in fact
been further removed it was always quite
remote further removed from people
themselves and the decisions that are
being made at the high level beyond
popular control basically respond to the
Dorgan banks not the depopulation
the level of austerity has had a dire
economic effects on large parts of
population that it is anger rage peak
when we turn near his trunk listening to
this constituency yeah oh he has one
major legislative achievement so forth
what thomas joseph stiglitz
properly calls the donor tax bill 1917
which forms the general population
Armstrong's constituency benefit is
actual differences
which is concentrated wealth and power
we've been observing in the United
States last year it's a sensible system
in which the figure in the White House
focuses attention on himself but
immediate attention on from as having
showing up the falsity is often
forgotten and what he's doing that of
the more savage main of the Republican
Party
Brian the rest ramming through
legislation which is extremely harmful
to their pretendin statements of their
voters and everyone else contracting the
world in general so we cannot forget why
in the Doomsday Clock that's four
minutes to midnight that's an
overwhelming fight for passing
everything else we're discussing and
it's largely because their needs
actions that are being taken under the
others it's a good game but it's very
well but it's extremely dangerous
yeah Bennet leading the rage anger
irrationality and some funds support for
Paris Matic figures represent four
motivates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute of Arts and ideas
at AI TV